[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Pizza time
this is gonna be my Doctor Strange two
multiverse of madness video muffled made
a bunch of big announcements Sam Raimi
confirmed that he is in fact doing
doctors trained to multiverse of madness
and talked a lot about what's going on
with the movie there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs including a bunch of
spider-man Tobey Maguire Easter eggs so
we'll break it all down if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what
kind of cameos you want to see during
Doctor Strange - pizza time we'll just
go down the list here starting with
number 5 if he didn't see the news the
other day Sam Raimi was talking about
Doctor Strange - during an interview he
was doing for a separate horror web
series he did recently to make as many
spider-man puns as possible this is what
he said about the Doctor Strange
character in about the movies so I'll
just read his quote here he said I love
Doctor Strange as a kid but he was
always after spider-man and Batman for
me he was probably a number 5 for me of
great comic book characters he was so
original but when we had that moment in
spider-man 2 I had no idea that we would
ever be making a Doctor Strange movie so
it was really funny to me that
coincidentally that line was in the
movie I gotta say I wish we had the
foresight to know that I was going to be
involved in the project talking about
having the foresight to know that he
would eventually one day direct a Doctor
Strange movie for the Doctor Strange
seemed that he is talking about is from
spider-man 2 when j jonah Jameson is
trying to come up with a name for Doctor
Octopus their first idea is Doctor
Strange what are we gonna call this guy
Doctor Octopus and that's crap science
squid crap Doctor Strange
that's pretty good what it's taken wait
wait I got it
Doctor Octopus so obviously the funny
thing about that is the Sam Raimi says
at the time he didn't think that he'd
ever be involved with a Doctor Strange
movie and so and he didn't have the
rights to the character so they wouldn't
be able to make that movie at Sony
anyway there were some rumors back in
the day that at one point he did try to
get a Doctor Strange movie going but it
was wave
before the MCU existed and nothing ever
came of it you may remember earlier this
year when people were talking about him
directing Doctor Strange - even scott
derrickson former director of dr.
strange - spoke up in favor of Sam Raimi
just saying that he was an amazing
person who he'd worked with before Raimi
was originally one of my top picks to
take over the movie after derrickson
left because the movie was supposed to
be an MCU horror movie in Sam Raimi is
probably one of the few people in
Hollywood who has a strong background in
horror in comedy as well as a strong
background in major studio comic book
movies aka all the spider-man whatever
you think about what happened with
spider-man 3
spider-man 2 with Tobey Maguire is still
regarded is one of the best comic book
movies of all time not just one of the
best spider-man movies of all time if
you're not sure what happened with scott
derrickson and why he left it's because
he had a big disagreement with Marvel
over the tone of the film and the
creative aspects and even though he and
Marvel haven't gotten into the details
you can kind of see what's going on if
you look back to this Doctor Strange -
comic-con clip from last year and then
the separate clip of Kevin Feige later
talking about the movie also pay
attention to what Benedict Cumberbatch
says during this clip - about the movie
because it'll explain another reason why
Sam Raimi is such a slam-dunk pick -
take it over I mean what excites me
about Doctor Strange is what made him
great in the comics that he doesn't
fight villains from this earth or even
from this universe but from the
multiverse of other dimensions so you
get into all kinds of psychedelic
weirdness which this movie is going to
but when I came and talked to Kevin
about doing a sequel I said I don't want
to do just another sequel to do a sequel
if I'm gonna do it it has to go into the
territory that drew me into the Doctor
Strange comics in the first place
which is how they dipped into the Gothic
and the horror and and the horrific and
we're gonna make the first scary MCU
film
you can't me at God you know you know
why
no it's pg-13 you're gonna like it I'm
really excited to be at the dawn of this
project and I think it's vital to
maintain the integrity of humor and
stuff that we had in the first film but
with this twist of horror which I think
will really have people crit so what
that comic-con panel scott derrickson
was hyping out dr. strange to is the
first real MCU horror movie a scary MCU
movie but then right after that real
quickly benedict cumberbatch piped up
about retaining the quote-unquote humor
in comedy of the first Doctor Strange
movie now you see why Sam Raimi's
background and horror comedy is so
important all you have to do is watch
Evil Dead 2 or army of Darkness one of
the funniest moments from that comic-con
panel was also Kevin Feige responding to
all the fans yelling at him because they
were so excited one of them in the crowd
you can hear yells rated R movie and he
quickly pipes up saying no pg-13 and
you're going to like it like he wanted
to immediately make it clear that there
was no way they were gonna make a rated
R Doctor Strange movie and because scott
derrickson 'he's background is mostly in
traditional rated r horror films it just
sounds like he wanted to make a legit
horror film in the MCU and kevin feige
is like no we're not doing that to the
best example of Sam Raimi doing horror
inside a comic book movie are the scenes
like this from spider-man 2 when they're
doing the Doctor Octopus origin scene in
the hospital right after his initial
accident
[Music]
I love the way they did those is
practical effects special effects from
that movie because it's so long ago
aren't quite as seamless as the special
effects from the modern films like a
benders endgame but if you remember all
the Doctor Strange scenes from Thor
Ragnarok Tyco by TD said that they did
most of those as practical effects
in-camera without having to use special
effects with him messing with Thor all
through the sanctum all those scenes of
them shifting from room to room the
stuff with the beer refilling itself
that's all practical effects but just in
terms of differences from the first
Doctor Strange movie what we know about
Doctor Strange too obviously is that
it's mostly dealing with the multiverse
as the title implies multiverse of
madness but it's also a lot more of
psychological horror they haven't
officially confirmed that Nightmare is
the main villain but because they
already knew what the story was going to
be back when scott derrickson was doing
it and he kept talking about Nightmare
it sounds like they haven't changed that
part of it think of a version of
Dormammu this more like Freddy Krueger
Nightmare on Elm Street messing with
people's dreams from an alternate
dimension but then somehow manifests in
the physical made reality the MCU the
whole concept of Nightmare and the
nightmare dimension is that the bonds
between dimensions between realities
weaken when you're asleep and that's
when he's able to penetrate people's
minds and mess with them but because the
one division series is supposed to set
up the beginning of Doctor Strange - it
sounds like something that Scarlet Witch
does with her children envisioned in
this alternate reality story that
they're doing creates some havoc in the
multiverse that the villain of Doctor
Strange - is able to exploit so imagine
them doing the Iron Man 3 trauma
storyline where Iron Man is still
experiencing all this anxiety and trauma
from the Battle of New York only the
nightmares that he sees in dreams start
to manifest in the real world so you
don't know what's real what's fake
I think Nightmare on Elm Street is
probably the best comparison to make so
think of it as Doctor Strange -
nightmare on Bleecker Street because
that's the street that the sanctum is on
but number one I know you're all asking
Tobey Maguire Spider Man Easter eggs or
even a full-blown cameo scene in the
movie what's going on if the movie is
all about the multiverse and because of
the major Doctor Strange Spider Man -
Easter Egg how can
not try to pay it off by referencing
Tobey Maguire spider-man somehow in
Doctor Strange - it just feels too
perfect
you don't even need to do it as a
full-blown cameo even Bruce Campbell
longtime Sam Raimi collaborator is also
asking for a cameo as a villain
character you may remember him from the
cameo in the first spider-man movie as
the emcee who introduces him into the
ring when he's getting ready to fight
that wrestling match what's your name
kid the human spider human spider that's
it that's the best you got yeah in
speaking of Doctor Strange spider-man
crossover Tom Holland still has that
mystery Marvel movie on his contract as
part of the big Sony Marvel of sharing
deal their current deal is for
spider-man 3 in another non spider-man
Marvel movie Doctor Strange and
spider-man both live in the New York
City area I don't know if they have
plans for any kind of Tom Horne cameo
during the movie right now Scarlet Witch
is supposed to be the other lead
character so I don't expect a whole lot
of spider-man stuff to be happening in
Doctor Strange 2 I think a really good
comparison to make for Scarlet Witch
Doctor Strange team-up vs. whoever this
multiverse villain is going to be is
that it's a lot like Doctor Strange
triumphs in torment which is the story
of Doctor Doom teaming up with dr.
strange because Doctor Doom is a magic
user and as science user to go to hell
to fight in the fist oh and save doctor
dooms mother so everyone just leave all
your predictions for Doctor Strange to
in the comments below if you didn't see
I'm also doing that big MCU Infiniti
saga re-watch project where I point out
all the big Marvel phase 4 Easter eggs
in the MCU movies my next video for that
will be for Iron Man 2 that should post
in the next couple of days
congratulations Billy Ken's it you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details
everyone click here for that Incredible
Hulk infinity Saga video and click here
for my new guardians of the galaxy three
teaser breakdown thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight